whoa what's up rejects in my name is
John this here is Greg we're going to
watch some [ __ ] today but first thanks
for tuning in
means a lot that we're going to watch
something we're going to trailer for the
book of Henry which is the new film from
Colin Trevorrow director of the
masterpiece Jurassic world and the
lesser-known safety not guaranteed if
you haven't seen that [ __ ] if the
charming movie I recommend you check it
out and remove this wristband everybody
hates who who requested this Greg wants
to tell you that is so funny how you
know to open up one app adjust a bunch
of different things to start like
popping up and getting in the [ __ ]
way what about this provide this oh well
the way you lay asleep or some battery
now mr.eddy silent gaming oh boy your
silence is not silent anymore Eddie
not now I once knew a guy named Eddie
Eduardo he was actually acts of a girl I
was dating it's cool is he hot yeah I
hated him for that
our legacy isn't how many comics here
and what make it go
it's we were looking at their lives and
what we can need them and not like me
again why we can't put you on a gifted
school kofedix on a cycle so paper well
booth for me to interact with a peer
group that it always going on
hi Susan I think he just said you have a
direct deposit if that's easier
I don't know well Kenny you'd ask your
eleven-year-old in our financial signal
into Milton yeah I forgot to give it to
you while you do it all by yourself
come on I am Henry find me another nail
of the species who more grown-ups in him
I like to the story about me with lovin
my mom and they grow who the big stores
and the artists they're lucky to have
you and your father's lucky to have you
soon
stepfather hey ink oh she hates Hank she
tell you something is very more marcin
is in trouble and someone hurts someone
else we have to make it better what is
going on
I supposed to do all myself but that's
not an option
in the world christina is a police
commissioner I'm not going to get into
public scrutiny without conclusive
evidence we do have the proof that he's
guilty
okay let's do it this might hurt
everything you need is right here I'll
be with you the whole time
I know it's done I'm talking to those
who think they have a wave it can't be
left undone no matter what we have to
make it better
what the [ __ ] oh Henry learn how to put
together a sniper and build it for her
Greg her woods a missing that him before
I wish when right when they flip the
page to the thing about like why there's
no other way I wish they just started
playing blurs there's no other way
that's something there's no other way
there's no other way because you know
it's really good I beat song for a
family film like this you know like
families coming together to bring down
man how heartwarming is that this looks
intense what do you think I was so
surprised with that trailer took a turn
like that yeah I feel like I need to
watch it five more times because like
the first half I was prepared for like
oh okay this is like a family drama this
kids probably gonna have to learn to
leave his mom one day like very
dependent on evermore or maybe he's got
like a secret world in the shack thing
out in the woods where you do a lot of
stuff oh it's a thriller artist kind of
disturbia vivid and now they're they're
[ __ ] cars yeah - the divine like
Mason the accountant meets disturbia
yeah there's a whole lot of trailer in
this I don't know this based on
something prior when I was watching like
the whole set up with you know genius
boy I was like oh that's fascinating and
then all that fascination kind of just a
little bit dwindled when it became so
plot centric about not evil Hank next
door doing some fucked-up things to his
daughter I thought I felt like they had
a cooler story to explore with wood boy
genius instead of this action thriller
who didn't like turned into white I
guess that's what confused me in the
past few years i watch more trailers
than I ever have and so like you know
over time you get to start to pick them
apart as art forms in and of themselves
I wonder about the whole movie in the
sense of like
first half of the trailer takes its time
and is like introducing you to you know
just this little family dynamic and what
their life is like and then halfway
through when it finally like puts in the
linchpin of the story you just [ __ ] it
rockets for me I'm like what is that
something like what's the pace like oh
god well I know you've been in seedy
accountant no but I feel like I'm gonna
feel the same way I did it I saw the
accountant which was like the beginning
of the accountant first like half hour
so I thought was really interesting Ben
Affleck in the accountant he's autistic
but he's a badass autistic dude you know
and I thought that was cool that they
really showed that how it's like it you
know being autistic and really be a
special gift as well that's why I'm
going to him then snakes in a little
lifestyle he lives and I thought that
was all rather fascinating and as the
plot was going I thought it was like
kind of cool but then when it became
like all right know that fascinating
[ __ ] we're just gonna go plot heavy to
hell I'm gonna come like alright here we
go
come on yeah yeah and I feel like that's
kind of where this trailer is gonna this
movie might be for me to wear oh the
first like half hour this is fascinating
of it's like really specially like
gifted do this genius boy and you know
he takes care of his mom's finances and
oh yeah that's fascinating she seemed
like she's really dependent on him like
she won't find a husband she doesn't she
won't find a man to move on with like
that all the man I need with him right
there ya know weird way it seems like
she's can she's perfectly can be as in
this little life it seems to work like
it seems like maybe it's a little lonely
but it seems like it works enough I'm
just not seeing how him all those
elements of him being boy genius are
going to you know necessarily affect
like show wouldn't he like his special
abilities on how he's able to take down
being Norris is his name yeah
it's how he's able to take down being
Norris cuz you know she's like he
documented everything
like what did you like some types of
special documentation about this yeah
because that's the kind of thing I
imagine that goes beyond you know just
jokey do it son what are you seeing
because just the makeup but you have
your intellect applicable what seems
like sneaking around you have advanced
abilities like crawled oh yeah a
building so insidious yeah genius stuff
really be enhanced even more throughout
the film because I'm like the genius boy
part is the fascinating part of the
story to me that seems to not really
matter so much once it becomes by the
time you get to the end yeah I think
that it doesn't it seems like weird a
ami wants a sniper all of a sudden you
know the trailer seems forget and that's
what interests me about trailers now the
more we watch them is sort of like what
is this reflecting out of the whole
movie is this a good portrait of what
the movie might look like just in a very
setup format or are they trying to sell
me certain themes yeah because I get I
can see like this is one of those
trailers where it comes together I can
almost see the movie being like that but
maybe it's not I want to call in
trevorrose fans I like I like his work I
even like Jurassic world Jurassic
world's fun like I don't I don't dislike
dress world through and thro think he
did like a bad job with it like I feel
like it's directions probably fine
I like safety not guaranteed like that
that movie left more than pressure I
mean in Jurassic world I'm interested to
see a Colin Trevorrow joint back on this
scale because to me you know like
Jurassic world is is so big and has so
many moving parts and so many people
involved that I don't know that if I
want to just judge his career based on
that movie because it's clearly she's
trying to do something else now
I think his castings cool you know there
are a lot of like comedians and this who
are doing you know what looks like a
little more of a serious role and safety
not guaranteed had that too I'm happy
that he's not just being blockbuster guy
right now you know he seems like he's
taken on you know going back doing a
small project before he doesn't does the
next giant thing I think that he's got
the chops and there are definitely good
people involved in this I mean they only
want I know she has misfires every now
and again but it doesn't seem like she
just chooses anything for the sake of T
nah she doesn't and she's a terrific
actress and you know like Sarah
Silverman is a pretty good dramatic
actor
it seems like she does a lot of dramatic
work sort of off the grid or also like
mainstream grids work for Dean North you
know Lee pace is in here somewhere I
think it could be cool I just don't know
what to think about this since the
second half I guess part of it is to
throw you off
you know because no one expects this
situation to come in like if you're in
the shoes of these characters like where
lives are where they're at you know
where Naomi Watts and boy genius or up
they're not going to expect such a dark
thing to suddenly occur next door you
know it is a two minute trail out of a
full length movie the thing is it's
trying to show you a lot where oh
they're going to have their conflict for
a while of should they do this he's
going to find out more reasons why and
they have that cool scene that I like
that touch where in the notebook it says
you know why not doing this won't help
ya why there's nothing else we can know
there's no other option and then him
planning it out and everything like that
I can see it working together there is a
version of this that I could definitely
see working with what I've seen yeah you
know but there's also a version of this
or I can see it not work yeah this
trailer gets kind of unwieldy headers
there mid with both around like a part
of me could definitely see it another
part like I'm not too sure actually but
it could be cool it give you a fun
thrilling if anything it doesn't look
like it's going to be shy of
entertaining oh yeah yeah this is
something that I'll at least keep my eye
out for you know I'm curious to see how
it turns out what's his way to arrive
tomato says yeah and then we then will
decide if we should go watch a movie
ever
yeah we'll let them tell us how to feel
subscribe to the real rejects John his
reasons Jerry on Twitter and Instagram
he is the social media manager of blunt
house and the real rejects if that
doesn't interest you to go over there
and find out what that means I don't
know how else to say it goodbye